I think it's pretty clear that the kind
of content that will be coming out
leading up to the Super Bowl 50 years
from now will be produced by most likely
internet conglomerates traditional
television powers 50 years from now they
may still be broadcasting the game but
it would be much like we look at radio
now it'll be something that maybe your
parents do it or even your grandparents
there's no doubt that part of your NFL
consumption will be off the television
set and on to either your laptop your
computer your cell phone or whatever
we're using 50 years from now but the
majority of football fans are going to
be online whether they're watching it
there whether their second screening it
the second screen is most likely going
to become their main screen max back to
the resin
the viewing experience is going to be
beyond what we can think of now and I
would say think very niche where you can
almost be your own director and create
your own broadcast experience at home if
you want to focus on one single slot
receiver for the game if you want
virtual reality and so you can watch the
game essentially from the quarterback
position super advanced kind of
production where I mean you almost can
feel like you know you are getting run
over at the goal line so now the average
friend is gonna see hey you know what
I'm carrying the football right now and
have another player in your ear saying
okay this is what we're looking at you
know what this is the this is the a gap
this is the big app this is a see gap
this is how the offensive line of
blocking you know what is a performer
player actually thinking or what does a
player currently thinking about while
he's on the field we're already seeing
how technology changes the fans
relationship with the game things like
Twitter and I enable us to come in in
real time about the game to discuss
strategy in real time with people all
around the world I think that's only
going to increase that the person
sitting at home is going to be able to
say you know I cannot believe that
Russell Wilson threw that crossing
pattern down at the goal line that
Malcolm Butler intercepted and we are
going to go well not me because I'd be
108 years old but that we are going to
go into locker rooms and in you know on
fields and we're going to ask players
hey you know we had a great question
from a guy in lawrenceville georgia and
he wants to know Russell
in the world could you have thrown that
and his answer will go directly to the
guy in Lawrenceville Georgia so I just
think it's going to be more and more
personal more and more direct contact
between the American public and through
the news media with the players who they
want to read about in here boo you look
at the axis they have now and players to
cry it but it's only going to get more
invasive when it comes to the guys in
the locker room the coaches in the
meeting rooms we're going to know guy's
heart rates during the game we're gonna
know guys how far they've run on each
play we're going to know all the things
that maybe we didn't even know we wanted
to know but now that information is
going to be at our fingertips everything
we talked about when it comes to hard
knocks you've seen how that's grown more
and more the NFL now is mandated in four
teams you just wait you think it's all
inclusive now it's not even close it's
going to get ten times that 50 years now
you